hello and welcome to incite Germany my
guest today is a novelist who grew up in
Kenya studied in Britain and came to
live in berlin in 2002 priya basil
worked in Lund in a london advertising
agency before becoming a full-time
writer she's written three books so far
and she also co-founded something called
authors for peace a couple of years ago
a platform for writers to use literature
as a way of promoting peace welcome to
the show you've written your novels here
in Germany but none of them are set in
Germany why is that well when I came to
Germany it was in sort of rather special
circumstances I had studied literature
and I had wanted to write but I think I
was intimidated after studying I thought
what makes me think I can do that and I
sort of went sideways into advertising
think it would be creative and you know
also a good career and just found myself
increasingly miserable and my partner
who's German said to me you're always
talking about wanting to ride you're
really unhappy why don't you come and
spend some time in Berlin try and write
and see what happens and so I had this
amazing chance just to try and follow my
dream and I arrived in Germany not
speaking a word of German not knowing
anybody apart from Matty my partner and
just with this story in my head which
was partly a story based on the journey
of my family from India to East Africa
to Great Britain so at that point he
didn't even enter my head that the place
I was writing in might have some
significance to the writing itself what
I did find though was that being
relatively isolated here was actually
ideal for writing because it gave me
this kind of space for contemplation and
aloneness that is necessary for writing
and is it easier to write about a place
after you've let it left it because you
write your books are
setting Kenya so one of them ishika mush
starts in India is it easier to write
about things when you've left them is it
have you got a very good memory hahaha
I've actually got a terrible memory I
have to confess no you have oh I mean
they put the thing with writing fiction
of courses that you don't need to rely
on the memory doesn't need to be
absolute for you to use it no you can
you can use impressions and sort of hazy
reminiscences yeah but you're right he
is very descriptive gain is reading it
I'm in there I'm in India or I'm in
Kenya well um I think I would have been
able to write about these places had I
still been there and it's just my fate
that I've left the places where I lived
and started and maybe in that sense they
they have a different pool on the
imagination I mean for example is quite
surprising to me that both my novels are
partly set in Kenya because so perhaps
naively I thought well this was a nice
place that I grew up but actually you
know it hasn't had that much influence
on me really I mean now I feel like it's
sort of crazy that I ever managed to
delude myself that was the case because
of course it's formed me in so many ways
but it was only really when I started to
write that this became clear to me that
Kenya was a really important part of my
life and for my character my political
attitudes and so in a sense that
distance I guess being away allowed me
to see the place in a way that I
wouldn't have seen it had I still been
in it and I think it gave me a critical
distance because second novel in
particular is very critical about Kenya
and society and the corruption and that
was something people there didn't like
when it was reviewed and I think I might
not have seen those things on might not
have had the courage to save them in the
same way who didn't like it when it was
reviewed you mean in Kenya in Kenya yes
yeah they were very they were upset but
you know who was I saying these things
about the society
and I think that you know this question
of what you have the right what you have
the right to talk about what legitimacy
do you have is something that can be
difficult as a writer I always felt that
I was writing about a place that was
close to me and that I knew and
therefore I could judge would it then in
the future with this in mind would it be
difficult to write perhaps about the
society here because it's not so corrupt
or I mean she yeah well it's not just
easy to write about things because
they're bad but no I think that you just
start to have a different relationship
with what you write about i mean at the
moment you know what i'm writing isn't
set in kenya at all and I mean I'm
coming slightly closer to germany in the
sense that i think a bit of it will be
set in South Tirol so well they speak
German so you know I can imagine the
sort of evolution to where i am writing
more about where I am because you write
about the things that interest you and
that trouble you and you want to
understand more and after a while the
past has maybe you've grappled with the
things that most you know had the
biggest hold on you for a while and then
new things have to take that place and
that comes from the present now you were
born in London but left when you were I
just had one year old spent your
childhood in Kenya but you come from an
Asian background so do you consider
yourself British if anybody asks me you
know what are you i would say British
but you know it's it's a bit something I
say with a whole lot of qualifications
because obviously the Indian aspect of
my density is very important the fact
that i grew up in kenya and the fact
that i now live in germany means i think
of myself more as a European as well and
so it's nothing that I feel comfortable
with I mean these kind of labels of
identity I feel like there are so many
different facets to the identity and I
think the way that I feel most
comfortable
all describing myself is by saying that
I'm at home in the English language
because i feel as though that somehow
unites all my disparate worlds even
Jeremy some extent because people here
have been so generous about speaking
English that I was lazy for years about
starting to learn German yeah yeah we've
got a one or two pictures from your own
personal archive and I think this is so
sweet do tell us about that well this is
a shot of my sister and I in Nairobi and
I think it sort of sums up the
relationship quite well which is that i
was miss bossy boots and my sister in
yellow yeah i'm in yellow my sister was
who's a year and a half younger than me
Seema was my very willing follower and
slave for until she was about eight and
which one I had a crisis when she
suddenly beside us you had her own mind
and I was no longer going to call all
the shots I think it took me a very long
time to get over that I think somehow I
still haven't quite you know yeah got
over the fact that i can't call all the
shots all the time and another picture
this is of the the well three
generations of your family and shows the
diversity I think I mean is interesting
you saying that you don't feel British
you the English language sort of
describes you better tell us about the
family a bit where well in the middle of
the so far my grandparents mumsy and
puppetry Papaji actually died two months
ago and they on either side them once
has my mother and their son left my
uncle and then my aunt and cousins and I
think it's really interesting i chose
this photo partly because some of the
people who are in that photo are no
longer there so I pass through death or
through divorce or through separation
and I think that's so interesting with
families that there is this con this
shifting sort of yeah arrangement of
members and that's very normal these
days even though mean if my grandparents
are still very upsetting that you know
their children and grandchildren get
separated and divorced and also because
it shows but you know my uncle for
example married and English
you see my sister and I in the
background with her with her Scottish
boyfriend me with my German boyfriend
and so I love the way that this family
has really in a sense lived up to its
its roots because my grandparents moved
and so they were Wanderers they were
they were adventurers in that sense and
we've kept up that tradition by
wandering to me in terms of the way we
love so you know other people and then
I've continued to by moving to Germany
continued a journey in a sense the
immigration journey do you feel you're
settled here then now or do you think do
you think you have that vanda lust as
they say to move around um I feel pretty
settled I'm still very curious but I
feel more settled here than I would have
imagined possible I somebody had told me
you know 15 years ago that I would end
up living in a German city with a German
man I I would have really I would have
said no that's not my destiny and yet
here I am and I feel but this is Berlin
especially is really a city that I feel
very at home in I think it has
everything I want from a big city it's
sort of culturally it's so rich and it's
got you know you could go to different
art exhibition every week and still not
see everything and yet it's sort of calm
and I feel it's a very humane place to
live and I like that very much ok we'll
talk more about that in a minute there
the other day our reporter met up with
priya basil and she took him to one of
her favorite spots it's very peaceful
there it's where many famous authors
have found their final resting place
you
for me walking as part of writing every
day the walking part is as necessary as
the writing after britain i always go
for a walk to the strange to me that
that i find the suppressant experience
because i'm sure if someone had told me
that in some years time you'll be
walking in cemeteries every day I would
have thought how strange how morbid but
actually I find it very serene very
peaceful I love the fact that there
aren't many people there and i'm also
very moved always looking at all these
people who are gone but still remembered
the tombstones the names
it must have been also than he loved or
something
that's kind of funny my shadow one
battle Brecht when it's actually the
other way around and all these amazing
writers are actually casting shadows
over me as I write what I didn't know
was with no way the international
literature festival in Berlin has been a
sort of key for me into berlin's
literary life since I met a fiver in
2010 I think as though lots of doors
opened into another world that I wasn't
part of beforehand
we have been inviting priya for the last
three years because she's an outstanding
author her books are fabulous and she's
dealing with very important subject of
the contemporary world with belief with
intercultural relations and we feel
gifted to know that she is living in
Berlin oh now you can breathe
blue
it's strange actually to be in a city
where history is so potent and so loaded
and I like it I like it that I'm forced
to reflect again and again
I like the way the transparent as well
and so you sort of see yourself and then
let me see everybody else to and the
sense of continuity that life goes on we
go on and yet we still have to remember
before we move on if you'd liked a
signed copy of one of my guest books
they're here I'm framed by both books
first one is ish and mush I hope I'm
pronouncing that right perfect which
translation would be loved and smell the
second one is called the obscure logic
of the heart this one here please write
in to us at inside a DW de and include
your postal address in case you're our
lucky winner send it through the post
across you can also write in to comment
on the show we do like to hear from you
they were at the Berlin Wall memorial
obviously I worked it out I did the math
you were about 11 or 12 when the wall
came down did you remember it had told
you do you remember hearing about it no
not at all I think I was pretty cut off
from that sort of stuff in Nairobi I
mean in i must say that i lived in quite
a bubble then it's surprising to
consider it now but it was a sort of
small bubble of privilege my family was
pretty wealthy and we didn't I'm I
wasn't I don't know I mean I didn't
really notice of things that were going
on around me that you know that's only
people were so much poorer that there
was such obvious injustice and I also
wasn't so aware of what was happening in
the wider world it was a very an
existence very rooted in where it was
with little sense of what else was
happening in the world mm-hmm God's
obviously changed now here in Berlin you
said it in the report strange being a
city where history is so potent and
loaded how does that affect you this
history here in its mainly think very
hard about what it is to be part of a
history like the German history I mean
obviously as in all British schools the
Third Reich is you know one of the main
topics and so I knew about it roughly
and yet to be here and to see how people
negotiate that history on a daily basis
has been really fascinating I think that
it's been done really sensitively and
Intel
gently in Berlin and I guess they had
that special chance because it became
the capital quite late there was a sense
of you know rebuilding this place to
reflect a lot of what happened in
Germany's history and I think you feel
that the thought has gone into it and
yet it's discreet too because it's not
that you're sort of it's in your face
all the time I mean if you think of the
little cobblestones for example that
that installation by its German artist
oh these are these oh you mean the
little things on the on the ground all
through all through the city Jewish
people lived yes and the names of those
who were taken away you know you could
be walking along and not see them at all
and yet once in a while for some reason
you're I will catch and you'll look down
you'll see these names and you'll
remember and I like that sense of
surprise but you know your sort of
sometimes caught unaware and made to
think a little bit more but you can also
go around doing what you normally do
without always being conscious so your
attitude to certainly from the time in
Kenya where you say you're living in a
bubble what you think of Germans and the
J and Germany now is completely
different presumably yeah and also there
was a very active choice to be more
aware of what's happening in the world
because it seemed to me that this this
past indifference was just not very good
or very viable I want to be engaged I
want to know what's happening and I want
to also try and be part of things to
influence things let's talk about
writing and books because this this
country we in the in the piece there
there was talk about the international
book festival which you're a part of in
Leipzig there's a huge book fair in
Frankfurt there's a huge fair em there's
nothing comparable I don't think in
Britain really is there's on such a
scale I mean the Germans read don't they
are in a big way yeah I books absolutely
that's very true and that's been it's
lovely to be a writer in a society that
really values books and writers I mean
I'm not saying they don't in the you
but you're right that it's on a
different scale here and I think it's
partly that writers have a different
value still in German society I think
people look to writers as kind of maybe
moral conscience of a society is quite
it's n it's quite a heavy way to say it
but I think they look to writers as
models and examples and expect writers
the sort of lead you know social lead on
social issues and discussions and and
that's something that I I admire and I
think you don't have to do that as a
variety but if you want to there is a
platform for that in Germany in the UK I
mean I hear people talk about their work
and they might be asked oh did you want
to make a point about you know the NHS
and your booking and they would say oh
no no I mean that was just a sort of
here that happened by the by but that
wasn't really my intention and people
sort of downplay always the political
aspect of their book says it's just a
very different sense of water writers
role is in society now you love people
watching I know this because on your
website there's little film and you once
followed a man because of the way he
answered his phone I mean right as I
accept our observers but are you nuts I
a beautiful woman following a man
through the streets wonder what happened
well I will admit to being a little bit
crazy and I think probably you need to
be 22 right well because I mean that
comes from a very deep curiosity about
people and I think my curiosity can
somehow be actually a bit of a liability
to because I I get very caught up in
people's lives even people i don't know
yeah i thought myself i remember going
to a party and meeting woman who'd had a
problem with her legs and she sort of
talk a little bit about it we came home
and I couldn't get her out of my head
and part of me wanted to google to see
what i could find out that might be able
to help her and I said to Matt Ian do
you think I could get back in touch with
her and tell her I found out this so I
mean which is sort of senseless and
unproductive but it just shows you a
little bit of the way that the
imagination works or mine works which is
that I get very caught up with little
things about people and then I sort of
that
grows and grows in me and mostly it's
fine because I can channel it into my
writing but sometimes it can just be a
bit consuming in a not very yeah
constructive way I also get the
impression you strongly believe that
right writing can change things in the
world is this why you co-founded our
authors for peace and that one in my
second novel the obscure logic of the
heart I ended up writing a lot about the
illegal arms trade and I was very
shocked by this and the fact I mean
there is now I think we're moving
towards an international writing arms
trade treaty but when I finished writing
I thought I want to be able to talk
about political issues more not just in
my work and yet on what authority do it
do I do that from what platform you know
as a new writer you're not always given
a chance to talk about what you believe
in and so I thought let let me do
something where my voice can join with
other voices so that our voices are
amplified because they're together and I
was actually I worked with the
literature festival in Berlin the
festival director overachiever he helped
us to launch this platform we started it
with a piece a reading for peace in 2010
on his National Peace Day and 82 authors
from around the world came together and
read for 24 hours continuously from
their works and made different
statements about peace and it was a very
symbolic act but that was fine because I
think that you know action start from
symbolic movements and and since then
we've done a lot of different
initiatives and you know them yeah well
we've got one coming up my guess is the
author priya basil and not long ago she
marched on the government quarter here
in Berlin with a number of other writers
in a protest all about personal freedom
writers marched on Berlin's Chancellery
this sep tember to demand action over
the ongoing NSA spy scandal the group
among them many of Europe's leading
literary lights came armed with boxes
full of signatures and an open letter
which they recited in unison outside the
Chancellery to scores of journalists the
group hopes that their protest will
highlight a situation they feel is out
of control they want Germany to take the
lead on data protection and to tighten
existing laws they claim are two lakhs
divine even we want to make people aware
that it's an important problem for our
society in the 21st century do we really
want to be observed by who knows who we
demand a response to all of these issues
he's a [ __ ] the writers actions come
amid a global outcry over the breadth of
the United States spying operations
revealed via information leaked by
former CIA contractor Edward Snowden
shortly after this protest it emerged
that German Chancellor Angela Merkel's
personal phone had been tapped by the US
National Security Agency prompting US
Secretary of State John Kerry to admit
that intelligence gathering has gone too
far the writers agreed and demand that
Europe's leaders stand up and fight for
personal freedoms they feel have been
dangerously eroded as was said there
shortly after that protest we heard
about angler Merkel's personal phone
being tapped I mean this whole thing's
really exploding now isn't it absolutely
the aether was quite interesting that
anger manag Merkel only really spoke up
when it was her own phone but had been
tapped and we've been feeling that angry
for quite a few months miss Merkel and
but I was glad that you know it's sort
of it hit home in that regard I mean
when I compared the discussion in
Germany to that in the UK I'm really
struck by how much louder it is here and
and I feel really lucky to be part of
society where people are bothered and
are taking action and are resisting
because I think this is such an
important issue in terms of our personal
freedom and our democracy I think we
often think of freedom is something
but you know the ability to speak out in
public or to do what you want and we've
forgotten that freedom is also the right
to be private to be unobserved I mean I
think we can only be ourselves if there
are spaces in which we are not observed
and what these revelations have shown us
is that that space of privacy is really
really shrinking and if we don't act now
to you know try and stop that then we
we're reaching a point of society where
there's total information control do you
think it has something also here to do
with I mean you weren't here but there
was there was East Germany until
nineteen eighty nine or nineteen ninety
actual and there everybody was being
listened to and everybody was informing
on everybody else do you think that's
partly to you know the Germans are very
aware absolutely I think having a
history like that certainly makes you
much more sensitive but I think
sometimes the present is its own best
messenger and you know we don't all need
very difficult histories to recognize
that something really terrible is
happening right now and that we have to
act to stop it talking of the present
then has anything come out of that
protest well I think that there is an
ongoing discussion in the media I mean
that got a lot of attention and since
then the revelations that have continued
to come up means that the story is still
is I think spreading and catching more
more people in terms of the writers
actually there is an initiative going on
right now I'm not at liberty to say more
about it but I would say you know watch
this space because we're not giving up
and is this writer's for peace well me
as me as authors for peace involved
involved in an initiative with other
international writers including unity
and we're working on an initiative right
now which will be telling people more
about in a few weeks all right let's
move on to a wonderful questionnaire I'd
like to go you responded to our
questionnaire beautifully I have to say
and I would like to ask you if you
firstly you put down as your top down
everybody
Stan Berlin and you did put that but you
also put lubick yes which is right in
the north of the country why do you like
Lewis well it's a lovely hanseatic city
I mean it's beautiful just cobbled
streets lovely old churches so it's
really atmospheric and I know Lewbert
because that's my partner's hometown and
so it's where we end up going at least
once or twice a year to visit his mom
and family exactly but I think it's very
special also because it was thomas
mann's city and its great also yes I'll
shoot so it has these other residences
then going to grass the other great
German writer also was from lubick and I
think still has a home there I think in
the same street as my partner's mother
so it has all these lovely resonances
family personal ones but then also
literary ones and so it's that that's
why I like it very much and you put down
as your coolest living German a little
boy remember tell us about this little
boy because this is all about
multicultural yeah thnkx here he's
called Seraph alloy firm and he's a
little Ethiopian boy that my neighbors
adopted two years ago and I chose him as
my cooler stone because for me he
represents the future of Germany a more
multicultural future and when I first
came and started spending time in Berlin
11 or 12 years ago it was a less
diversity than it is now and it makes me
really happy when I walk through the
streets now and I hear different voices
and I still don't see as many different
people them but you hear lots of
different European accents and and
languages and that's wonderful and I
think more and more I can imagine that
changing to the point what we have
actually lots of different people and
Berlin I know that other German cities
that are already much more multicultural
like Frankfurt stood guard I think even
Munich was gonna be my next question
yeah but I'm and that's really nice but
they're still not it's still not like
London I mean London extraordinary when
you go there and you just feel as though
the world is here and that's beautiful
i'm not saying that everywhere needs to
be equally make
because you know that's not an ideal
it's just it's nice when it happens but
I think that you know it's important for
a society to be open to others and and
sewer fell represents for me this idea
of an openness a different kind of
future yeah another one useful German
product is the fixed book price which
people most probably out there do not
know about so we should explain that
then let me well yes the fix book price
we don't have it in the UK you still
have it in Germany it's fantastic where
buy books cannot be discounted beyond
the agreed price so you can't have this
as you do in UK and American book shops
where you go in and you know it's 342 or
you know the price slashed and
supermarkets down to you know five
pounds or five dollars for a book books
are still pretty expensive in Germany
but they are also have a very different
value because of that yeah and and I
looked it up I research this the Germans
buy more books actual books per capita
than any other country I know even
though they're not sort of slashed
prices yes yeah because they love books
um I mean you really feel that when you
go to readings you go to events I mean
one funny thing is just the German
stamina for listening readings you know
you have readings here that go on for
half an hour and also just reading and
people are very attentive you know in
the UK you never have a reading for more
than five or ten minutes and then
there's chatter and then maybe you read
again but just I think that the
attentions fan also says something about
the attitude to reading and and yet the
value again she think their attention
span generally for other things as well
as better I don't know that I can
comment on that generally I think it's
also a generational thing isn't it I
think in different societies with the
new media I think we we feel sometimes
that you know younger people haven't got
the same attention span because they're
switching between things all the time
but then again the popularity of harry
potter suggests even young people can
read a long book it's just if it has to
be good and grab them
um so yeah I think I wouldn't I wouldn't
be able to say that general Germans are
generally more no sorry I mean I just
wondered off the top of my head
ingenious German invention energy vendor
when it's not really an invention is it
I don't know and this is the energy
transition away from nuclear that's
right I found this quite extraordinary
you know have more sustainable energy
and I love the fact that in Germany
through the seneca vendor movement the
people have taken control of the energy
so i mean at the moment 25% of germany's
energy comes from renewables and about
sixty-five percent of that is made by
the people by the german population and
and they expect that by 2050 eighty
percent of germany's mg will become from
renewables I mean while this means that
the hold of the power companies is
really shrinking and if you compare it
to the UK right now a power price
they've gone up by ten to thirteen
percent you know people have no control
over it everybody's really unhappy the
company is making huge profits and here
people make profit because they can they
make their own energy then they sell it
back to the grid and I think that's
quite wonderful as as an alternative
thing that a man will be in the hands of
the people well it is already a
significant chunk of the renewable
energy is already and I mean of course
there are still things to fix then the
grid needs to be expanded in different
storage mechanisms it's an ongoing
process but I think what has been shown
is that the people can take care of
their own energy needs with the right
government incentives and government
support and I mean people now argue that
in fact the only reason it's taking
longer is because the government's
trying to protect the energy company's
interests so I think I think of it as a
wonderful example of a sort of you know
grassroots movement where people have
managed to take control of something
that mattered to them because very often
we feel as though we can't do anything
we can't change anything but it's it is
possible with the as you can see through
a movement like that have you got solar
panels on your roof we don't have solar
panels but we do have a
an energy production unit in the
basement of our house and we actually
use gas to make energy but we can also
use wood pellets so it's not it wouldn't
be my first choice of energy sort of
production but we I live in a place
where we voted on it and the majority
wanted that yeah well would I just show
a picture another this is another of
your pictures it doesn't look very
exciting in itself but now I'm sure it
was exciting it was hellas what it was a
very special I mean there's me and in
what finally became our apartment sort
of waving when it was still very much a
construction site my partner I became
part of something called the bow
gemeinschaft in Germany which building
building cooperative operative right and
this is basically when like-minded
people come together they cut out a
developer and they build their own place
and we did this about seven or eight
years ago and and we now live in this
apartment block with eight other
families and it's been a real surprise
for me because it's like being part of a
community in a way that I'd only felt
before with my family and it's also
something that's helped me feel like I
belong here a bit more we talked about
belonging before this has been part of
my sense of you know being able to
imagine staying on here yeah well we'll
hear more about my guests experience
with a building cooperative in a minute
first of all though let's have a look at
another similar project to explain it
all also here in Berlin
my guest is the author apria basil and
who you've had a similar experience to
that you know a cooperative building a
house now you must in this cooperative
have these meetings of all although that
have they been has mixing with how
Germans like to do things and how you
might like to do that yes well I think I
wouldn't I found it no different to
perhaps meeting you know at any big
meeting between different people always
some tensions or slight difficulty but I
think there was just a general there was
such a general wish to build a nice
place for all of us to live that that
over road most the differences I mean
when we started the meetings actually I
didn't speak very good German at all I
spoke very little German and so that was
kind of my advantage so I could just
sort of you know blank out while this
bit when discussions got more heated and
it also meant that I wasn't that somehow
attached to what was going on because
you know I hadn't been arguing for
something and therefore feeling you know
I really want to make sure this this
goes through so in that sense I was
slightly protected from it now we have
much less meetings out that were just a
vulgar man shaft and living community
maybe to a year and and they tend to be
pretty pretty easygoing pretty nice I
think we're quite lucky I know that
they've been cooperatives where they've
had a lot of problems a lot of you know
very difficult discussions that have
stored for ages because there could be
no agreement sometimes I think the right
bunch of people we weren't so many that
made it easier we were all just really
wanting to have a nice home and and it
worked more simply than it has done for
others so do you feel this is home now
yes in a way I mean I was talking to a
friend of mine recently and she said
something to me she said its faces not
places which sounds a bit twee but I
felt like there was something very true
in that
but for me more and more because my life
and and my love's are so spread out i
mean my sister lives in australia now
you know my mom and my brother and my
dad my brother in kenya my mum's in the
UK and my uncle and my grandmother to
matthew CN some of my people I really
care about are in Berlin now and and I
go family visited here at all yes they
have yeah and I feel that we're where I
see the faces i love i do very quickly
feel at home and maybe I'm also lucky in
the sense that they're all living in
democratic open societies which you can
go in and out of easily perhaps it will
be different if they were in a more
difficult environment but yeah the faces
make home yeah that's true final thing
you've said here the best kept secret in
Germany Germans have a sense of humor
did you believe they didn't before you
came here well I mean I'm matching my
partner is a very ironic very funny
person and so I knew I thought okay well
there must be something maybe there's
something more to the German but what I
found so funny being here is the
political satire I mean there's one
story I especially love which was of
this a German party called depart I and
how they infiltrated the Liberals of the
local election in 2011 and they
basically started cheering when the
results came even though the Liberals
actually hadn't even made the threshold
there were all these people in there
cheering and sing yes we've done it
we've done it and it was I just thought
that was such a funny way to sabotage a
party and yeah they're very good on
political satire we'll have to leave it
there priya basil it's been tremendous
talking to you if don't forget to write
in but if you would like one of her
books signed if you're lucky winner
that's it from me until next week bye
bye
Oh